so when you look at tools for email
animation are several platforms you can
use a lot of startups are used SendGrid
which is a really cheap effective way to
send lots of emails that are custom and
you don't have to get into a lot of
heavy architecture installation to get
it done it can get up and running pretty
quickly when you get bigger and become a
larger company you can go to things like
responses Marketo that are much larger
much heavier integration they allow a
lot of other things that lets you do
targeting retargeting segmentation that
sound grid won't do so it really depends
on where you are in your company's
lifecycle and how many emails you do
have one of the best ways to generate an
email list is to get them to engage with
your content or your products on their
own if you do that there's already a
level of trust they've given you because
I've said I like your product I like
your content I like your company if you
don't do that you go and purchase a list
there's a high likelihood they're
probably not going to be customers that
are in your target assignment they're
going to unsubscribe and you're going to
be wasting your time and your money so
there's several ways you can get someone
to subscribe to your website usually
when you come to a blog like Udacity com
/ blog what we do is we pop up a little
box and it says want to hear more from
us click here and it's really an email
address and a submit button it's clean
it's simple and so great with them to
continue engage with your content
another way is when you have a sign-up
process again at Udacity one thing we do
is you have to sign up for our content
and for our courses so to consume a
course you have to give us an email name
at an email address your first name and
last name that allows us to understand
what you're interested in and
communicate with you just about the
topics that you want to hear from so the
biggest component email marketing that
markers need to realize is the fact that
when someone gives you your email
they're trusting you with that it's a
very personal thing it's similar to your
phone so you're letting someone contact
you whenever they want to you've
established a bond and a trust with that
customer you will break that trust by /
emailing them or quote unquote spamming
them what you really don't want to do is
hit them too often with the wrong
message you will increase that stress
and they will talk about you and refer
you to other people if you actually
maintain a good relationship with them
and send them emails they want when they
want the more you send them things they
don't want the higher likelihood they'll
unsubscribe from what you do and not
talk to you ever again there's a great
example of this if you look at the
emails I've gotten recently from Apple
they really only send you something when
a new proctor features announced which
is great because I don't look I don't
see like 400 emails from apple on my
stream another example is a consumer
goods company where I get emails from
them probably daily I subscribed once
but I never subscribed to get something
every day I took me about three four
weeks for I gave up on that
my unsubscribe from their emails inbound
marketing is a set of activities that
you take to engage with your audience to
get them to come to your site directly
these are these are things like blog
posts social posts things on Facebook
LinkedIn and Twitter that you engage
direct with your audience and get them
to come to your site you really don't
want to send the same person the same
message multiple times the best thing to
do is create a theme or a message that
relates to a certain thing you're trying
to promote and then make that custom so
for example when you talk about the
fourth of July you'd have messaging
around that holiday that would promote
your product in conjunction with what's
happening at the time timely messages
are extremely important to getting
someone to read it the more timely your
messages there's a higher likelihood of
them actually opening your email and
engaging with your product and company